[inaudible]
abstractions took us far.
They let us notice common features of objects throw away their differences and
end up with a general concept. But now that you have that abstraction,
tell me what are you going to do with it?
Once you see common properties and abstract them,
you aren't limited to applying your abstraction to the original objects that
sparked it.
You can find those same properties in new objects and in new situations.
This lets you learn. It lets you gain knowledge.
We've used the abstract round to work out formulas that apply to every round
thing.
Let's say I tell you I have a new round thing in my backpack that you've never
seen before in your life since you don't know what it is.
How could you possibly be able to tell me anything about it? Well, my friend,
once you've mastered abstract thinking, you see right past the charade.
We can use the same kind of abstract thinking to pick up on patterns in
language. There's something else in my backpack you've never seen before.
It's a creature called a f,
but I bet you already know exactly what to say when you see three of them don't
you? When you do that,
you're drawing on a past pattern you've seen in English.
Abstracting that pattern and applying it to this new instance.
You've never had to say that you've seen three Schweppes before in your life,
but by taking a pattern from your source and applying it to a target,
the answer was obvious.
If you've taken your fair share of standardized tests,
you've come across comparisons like this.
These puzzles are called analogies. More specifically,
this is a proportional analogy and it tests how good we are at abstracting the
meaning of one pair of words and applying it to the second pair,
but analogies like this might have even more to teach us about language and
thought. Think about it.
Doesn't the Schwab Schwab's thing work a little like one of these analogies?
If so,
just how far can we take analogies in our quest to learn and think and create?
You'll see this pattern of recognizing a pattern,
abstracting the properties of that pattern,
and applying that obstruction to a new instance over and over again.
Ooh, we might even call this a pattern of analogies,
but how do we abstract that and analogize those abstractions?
Thanks for taking the time to learn with me.